[Musique]
je vous fais un rapide topo vous
inquiétez pas ce sera pas long le
suspect a la trentaine de type caucasien
mesureront environ 1 mètre 80 la
dernière fois qu'il a été repéré c'était
hier entre 20h et 22h au croisement de
la 42e et de park avenue et suppose
qu'il s'est échappé par là nous avons
retrouvé sur les lieux du crime
bon j'ai l'impression que la petite
nouvelle aurait envie de partager
quelque chose avec tout le monde alors
allez-y des locales on vous écoute ah
non pardon mais en fait j'ai pas bien
compris par où il est passé
la part la remporte ainsi une porte
d'accord vous ne distinguez pas très
clairement une porte et un immeuble là
évidemment maintenant que vous le dites
c'est très clairement une bord quelque
chose me dit que je pensais pouvoir me
refaire des deux cas n'ont vraiment pas
à les et montrez nous ce que vous avez
non mais disons que moi le croisement
42e et parka rouge aurait fait un truc
comme ça je pas une pro en dessin mais
j'ai pris quelques cours après les 1000
et devoirs ouais ça vous semble plus
clair que le dessin que j'ai fait avant
et bien ce qui me semblait donc je
disais c'est le croisement entre la 42e
et park avenue oui bizarre c'est en fait
ma tatie elle habitait là mais j'allais
en vacances chez elle quand j'étais
petit quoi on dirait une photo en fait
c'est ça qui est fou c'est que ou ne
peut pas ne pas reconnaître le truc
c'est google maps dégagé flaubert deluca
vous retournez à votre pièce je vous
préviens je faisais à l'oeil alors vous
arrêtez tout de suite cette petite
provocation ou alors je vous colle six
mois aux archives c'est clair oui oui
c'est très clair je reprends donc voici
ce qu'on a retrouvé sur les lieux du
crime un duvet mais attention c'est là
que ça devient intéressant
une tronçonneuse vous voulez la jouer
comme ça at-elle quoi vous avez du grand
gémir
non en fait je voulais juste vous
montrer que j'étais volontaire est ok
très bien
voyons voir si avec ces deux lettres là
vous seriez capable de deviner de quel
délit il s'agit pour ça et là je vous
écoute maintenant aller en l'air ok
agression sur personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique
facile chez la guerre que vous voulez
aider les gars ça c'est la guerre que
vous voulez mais regardez si vous vous
mettez à ma place je vous jure que c'est
plus simple en fait
vous voulez prendre ma place n'est pas
du tout pas du tout c'est parce que je
voulais dire c'est que si vous prenez du
recul c'est hyper clair là un quart non
non ap non on va le nom prénom a eu à
hofu avait dit rôle à un des bons
écoutez ce mot n'existe pas d'être
clairement en train de la vente et là
j'ai l'impression que vous avez vraiment
envie de passer six mois aux archives et
je vous jure que c'est un mot existe un
vrai mais est ce que quelqu'un connait
ce mot non non non l important c'est
bien ce qui me semblait abbas et vol
oui c'est ça
dégagez flaubert vous savez quoi
on va régler ça une bonne foi pour toi
ta belle aubaine qui est avec moi je
veux bien ok des deux cas mais je vous
préviens vous arrêtez avec vos petites
embrouilles
si je perds c'est toute la brigade qui
passent six mois aux archives c'est
clair notre sort est désormais entre les
mains de deluca
c'est parti
on comprend rien passé on n'a pas le
temps qu'est ce que ça veut dire quoi
vous savez pas ce que c'est ne fait pas
ça s'est passé à n'y voir qu'un jeune
lost and damned thaïlande
non bourgeois
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que vous faites faire des
lucarnes et justement ça fait quoi ça
c'est encore tout ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
y'a pas un accessoire normalement salut
à tous et anna et laura on a une chaîne
youtube opère original c'est bon ça va
on a aussi on a une hernie discale
c'est original oui c'est vrai et
d'autant plus qu'on l'a en même temps et
ça c'est pas commun donc abonne toi à la
chaîne personnes tous abonnés mais du
coup c'est clairement la manière le quai